staying overseas for the second time
this year Britain's conservative party
will be choosing a new prime minister
Liz trust who took over just last month
said yesterday she will resign after a
series of policy mistakes led to
financial turmoil and a party Revolt
let's talk about what happens now with
British journalist John sopel a former
correspondent with our partners at the
BBC uh John good morning I want to know
what happens now but if you could help
me understand how that came to pass that
on Wednesday she says I'm a fighter on
Thursday she's out how did that uh
transpire and then yeah what happens now
because she had lost all authority she
had lost her party she had lost the
country people were Furious because all
their home loans are going to cost a lot
more if you go to the grocery store it's
going to cost more to fill the trolley
and I think people just blamed it fairly
and squarely on some calamitous missteps
I think the last time I spoke on CBS it
was after the queen had died and we
talked about service and selflessness
and stability and over the past six
weeks with Liz trust as prime minister
we have seen chaos and arrogance and
dysfunction and I just think it couldn't
go on any longer
she wasn't even given a chance to turn
it around John did that surprise you you
know that lettuce thing seem like a joke
who were you betting on at the time and
why wasn't she given a chance to turn it
around because I think that things had
gone so badly and she had nearly driven
the British economy over the edge of a
cliff which could have had huge
International repercussions as well and
there was just a feeling that she
couldn't take a step forward without
tripping over and then the conservative
party looked at the polls saw how
disastrous they were and thought if
we're going to end it we better end it
quickly and that's what they did
and now we're hearing maybe Boris
Johnson coming back do you think that's
do you think that's likely Gail I
thought it was Preposterous when it was
first aired that Boris Johnson could be
making a comeback but I'm now thinking
it is possible and if it happens it
would be the most astonishing and
remarkable and surprising comeback since
Bobby Ewing stepped out of the shower at
the end of season nine of Dallas when we
all thought he had died and frankly
Boris Johnson lost power because his
ministers rebelled against him they all
resigned they said enough he could be
back
meet the new boss same as the old boss
but yours is better uh what should
Americans take away from what seems like
a whole lot of turmoil in the UK this is
your uh would be the fifth uh new prime
minister in six years
I think having lived in America for
nearly eight years I know you think of
Britain as this stable
slightly conservative small C rather
formal Island I think our politics has
gone down a dysfunctional route that we
have seen in America and Boris Johnson
is a populist you've had a populist
president it attracts it gets people
fired up but we've got a choice now I
think in Britain between a technocrat
who could become the next prime minister
or a return to populism and it will be
fascinating to see which ways it goes
and in America look Britain works very
closely with the US on defense on
Ukraine on all manner of topics this is
going to be watched very closely in
Washington as well as around Britain
yeah absolutely uh it'll be fascinating
to watch also a little worrying whether
you live here or there John sopel for us
laying it all out John thank you very
much